buttons embarrassing himself on the
campaign trail again here is actually
swearing at a blue-collar factory worker
in Michigan after being called that over
his gun control plants
Wow Greg I guess his staff was trying to
control him but he shushed them
he sure was that a female staffer
shushing a female staffer is sexist
sexist I tell you I don't know I can't
this is gonna be a fun time you know he
gets mad he gets cranky he's like me
when I'm hungry all the time
look the Biden's message is not the
party's message his messages vote for me
and I will replace Trump the party
message is vote for Biden and Kamala or
Amy will replace him you know what
that's me he also lied about not willing
to go after people's guns here he is
admitting it watch this guy you're gonna
take care of the gun problem with me
you're gonna be the one who leads this
effort to to gun owners out there who
say well by an administration means
they're gonna come for my guns bingo
you're right if you have an assault
weapon the fact of the matter is they
should be illegal period all right so
Katie either lied or you didn't remember
what he said two months ago
I don't think Joe Biden would be able to
define assault weapon I'm not sure he
knows exactly what his policy would be
but you can look at the people who have
endorsed him bado who he said would be
in charge of his gun policy has
repeatedly called for the confiscation
of constitutionally protected ownership
of firearms ordered or door-to-door by
force from the government coming to you
and demanding that if you don't turn it
in you will go to prison Michael
Bloomberg has endorsed Joe Biden who has
spent hundreds of millions of dollars on
gun control efforts all around the
country to curtail Second Amendment
rights it's really interesting to watch
Joe Biden in this setting because these
are the kinds of voters that Democrats
have to win back to win places like
Michigan and Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
and there have going to have a very hard
time reconciling this woek attitude of
gun confiscation to a group of guys like
that there's 50 people standing
and they all probably feel very similar
about the Second Amendment and also then
trying to win back blue-collar workers
it's like putting a square peg in a
round hole this is not going to work so
you can't be for gun confiscation in a
crowd like that a blue-collar workers
from the Midwest and think that you're
going to win their vote back especially
when President Trump has provided
economic policies that they like one
what if Trump went up to a voter and
told him he was full of Shh and then
told them let's you know let's take this
outside I think you guys would applaud
yeah because you say hey you know what
that's Donald Trump he's being direct
he's being real you know about doing
that though I thought you know what he's
a straight shooter and I by the way I
don't think what you guys are having is
so wrong Joe Biden and all those
interviews you just saw said that what
he wants to do is not come and
confiscate or take away anyone's gun
governor Whitmer Michigan just said
yesterday that that what Anderson Cooper
hang on no that's not what he said what
is that one go assault weapons weapons
they're always a threat in terms of mass
murder
country which we have a problem with but
here let me finish this because I think
that when you think about what Katie was
talking about some strong NRA backer
they work on a vote for a Democrat
anyway his stand biden stan is forceful
it helps him with democrats and say you
deliver a strong message joe you come to
me strong I didn't see any
dilly-dallying or mental incapacity no
sudden they are Forks but I must say
today I must say at this table
I now understand that Joe Biden is the
Democratic nominee the way these guys he
might not make it to be the know that's
your wishes thinking what do you think
Dana well I think on the gun thing it's
pretty interesting the Bernie Sanders
used to actually have a pretty nuanced
view he was a supporter of gun gun rides
and if that sort of set him apart in the
Senate and I don't exactly know when it
changed but as the party moved further
left he moved with them and so now
that's pretty much party orthodoxy is
that the position that Joe Biden is
saying that he has now is the one that
he thinks can get him to the finish line
with for the Democratic nomination now
how does that play in a general election
now for suburban women
maybe it's better but for those
blue-collar workers that were Obama
trunk voters I don't know that
necessarily helps them get them back
maybe he tried to call the guy dog face
bunny soldier a key tip to that point a
key difference between because you guys
were talking about Trump and Biden I
can't recall a single instance of Trump
actually aggressively going after an
individual every single one of Joe's
tips are with a person the dog do when
he's talking to somebody it's going
after a person Trump goes after groups
fake news the media that kind of stuff
he snaps pretty quick